foreign
the real Anthony fauci book by RFK Jr
has left me with a bleak view of the
state of the world how do we move
forward and can trust be restored are
you positive thank you both much love
and not are you positive of the answer
that the person asked the question
hasn't yet heard but are you are you do
you have a positive outlook
all right
um let me start
I am simultaneously
first of all I was truly even though I
have spent literally decades thinking
about capture and the hazard that it
poses to us
I was thrown by the real Anthony fauci
that book
and frankly I don't know anybody who
spent serious time with it who wasn't
right I think even
Robert Kennedy was thrown by writing it
I know that Pierre Corey was thrown by
it even though he's been living the
horror story up close and personal right
in any case my point is
there's a difference between knowing how
dangerous this stuff is and how it works
in an abstract way and seeing how it has
unfolded with actual lives on the line
the especially the section of the book
that deals with
the prequel to covid which is HIV right
that you have the same players in many
cases you have the same Playbook right
and you can see the same consequences
strategies and tactics right it's it's a
jarring presentation right and to the
extent
that we have spot checked it there's
maybe one or two places that
it might not be as cautious as it might
be but overwhelmingly it is extremely
well documented and stands up to fact
checking real fact checking yeah
um
that said I do find that in one way I'm
more hopeful than I've been even though
I think things are far worse than
they've been right kovid was a
absolutely catastrophic failure of so
many essential elements of our system
that that
uh is reason for fear but
more people are awake than ever before
the number of people who have figured
out that something about the system was
lying to them that it was indifferent to
their potential death
um to their suffering to the loss of
loved ones that I think we have a better
chance now of having the conversation
that we five years ago couldn't have had
right what do you do now that your
journalistic system and your academic
system and your medical system have all
failed you at this level right what do
you do what do you do with the fact that
we don't have we have isolated
journalists and we have no
um Mains we have no high-powered
journalistic Publications which can be
trusted
so
um
I don't think you're wrong about the
level of horror and the fact that it
might cause you to feel hopeless but the
other thing is we gotta hit bottom right
and to the extent that people can
convince themselves that their system
still functions they won't be motivated
to change it to the extent that they
know that their health was actually
jeopardized by A system that lied
through its teeth about what it knew
there is hope that they will change it
and I would say that is a piece of good
news that we haven't seen uh I don't
think in my lifetime people have been in
the dark and they are less so now they
are sadder but wiser
[Music]
thank you